monsieur le ministre il ya non je vous
interpeller sur les risques majeurs que
faisait courir les décisions fiscales et
financières prises dans la loi de
finances de 2010 8 sur la politique du
logement et le bâtiment les travaux
publics dans notre pays
nous souhaitons comme vous que l'on
puisse construire plus plus vite moins
cher pour reprendre le slogan de la loi
et l'ont d'ailleurs le président larcher
beaucoup de parlementaires ici de toutes
tendances vous ont accompagné dans cette
mission
mais on vous mettez en garde sur l'éco
la cohérence entre vos objectifs et les
mesures de la loi de finances de 2010 8
un an après les chiffres des neuf
premiers mois viennent de tomber
tous les experts je dis bien tous les
experts sont d'accord pour dire que la
construction neuve va rentrer dans une
crise très grave une récession grave en
zone urbaine et très grave dans les
campagnes et dans les villes moyennes
la situation est tellement grave que le
pdg de nexity a publié une lettre
ouverte au président dans les journaux
que le président de la fédération du
bâtiment vient de déclarer qu'on allait
tout droit vers la crise et annonce
probablement une perte de 200 mille
emplois dans le bâtiment à horizon de
2020 pour l'accession à la propriété ce
n'est plus un choc sur l'offre mais à
chocs de l'offre que ce n'est plus un
choc de l'offre bat socke sur l'offre
que nous constatons parce qu'il n'y a
plus de capacités d'emprunt
remboursables parce que le pouvoir
d'achat est en berne et que les mesures
que vous prenez sur le diesel en rajoute
une louche et en plus vous faites une
taxe sur les taxes pour les
entrepreneurs du bâtiment et des travaux
publics qui vont encore rajouter de la
difficulté notamment pour les pme pour
le logement locatif social c'est encore
pire puisque c'est 50% de moins
d'agrément l'année dernière par rapport
à 2015 si les permis de construire de
demain et c'est les constructions
d'après demain donc
bref tous les clignotants sont au rouge
et ma question est très simple en 2017
la politique du logement coûte est
certes cher va leur apporter beaucoup
plus pour faire baisser prix du logement
et relancer la demande
allez vous inversez vos mesures fiscales
qui vont nous faire perdre comme en 2014
un demi point de croissance et nous de
ramener tout droit dans le mur
l'année prochaine et l'année d'après
merci
soleil la parole comme ce marc fesneau
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
ainsi monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur daubresse vous donner quelques
éléments de réponse vous avez expliqué
l'absence de julien de normandie
certains spécialistes du sujet au moins
ça ne m'empêche pas de vous apporter des
réponses et je vous remercie de le
comprendre vous dire effectivement que
les chiffres que vous donnez sont exacts
vous dire aussi qu'ils sont une
comparaison des chiffres de 2016 et tout
le monde reconnaît que l'année 2016
avait été une année exceptionnelle en
termes de construction logement mais
cela ne doit pas se loi ne doit pas cela
ne doit pas nous exonérer cela ne doit
pas vous avez raison cernés c'est un
élément positif de votre bilan
comme quoi on sait reconnaître les
éléments positifs des bilans je voudrais
pas vous laisser débattre entre vous et
dont je voudrais vous apporter quelques
éléments de rampan de réponse vous dire
d'abord que nous avons pris des mesures
de soutien quand même à la construction
malgré ce que vous dites
le ptz a été reconduit pour quatre ans
c'est une visibilité qui n'avait jamais
été donné aux opérateurs le pin elle a
aussi été reconduit pour quatre ans
enfin je voudrais vous rappelez vous
l'avez dit monsieur daubresse la loi
élan la loi ayant elle vient d'être
votée et pourquoi elle a été votée
pourquoi d'ailleurs vous y avez les uns
et les autres beaucoup participé
notamment sénat c'était pour reconduire
une nouvelle politique du logement une
nouvelle coupe politique beaucoup plus
structurel de logements et je rappelle
quand même les mesures que vous avez
voté puisque la commission mixte a été
conclue ziv l'allègement des normes pour
réduire les coûts de construction
la mobilisation du foncier la rénovation
thermique des bâtiments avec près de 9
milliards d'euros qui seront consacrés
et 500000 rénovation qui seront portées
et puis aussi à baisser les coûts de la
construction au travers du digital aussi
il développé un certain nombre de
filières je pense par exemple à la
filière bois et la construction en bois
et le préfabriqué au sens ce prêt a
semblé si je peux dire est en fait la
dynamique des projets de territoire
parce que c'est ça aussi qui conduira
une politique de logement la dynamique
autour des projets coeur de gilles les
projets partenariaux qui seront
construits et les grandes opérations
d'urbanisme
l'état étant un facilitateur pour
s'élançant de ces projets non tout ne va
pas bien madame la sénatrice
mais l'objectif justement au travers du
projet de loi est lent c'est que tout
aille mieux
ce sont des réformes
turenne il faut qu'elles portent leurs
fruits et donc de nom le temps à ces
mesures de porter leurs fruits je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le ministre